Let's work on forming the /eɪ/ sound.
The tip of your tongue is relaxed and touching behind your lower front teeth.
This sound starts in the middle position on the front of the tongue.
/ɛ/.
From there, the front of the tongue lifts slightly, while the tip stays down.
/ɪ/. /eɪ/, /eɪ/.
/eɪ/, /eɪ/, /eɪ/.
Here's the /eɪ/ sound in the beginning of some words.
Eight, Aid, Aimed.
And here it is in the middle.
Playing, Staple, Bait.
And here it is at the end of some words.
Stay, Clay, Weigh.
Listen to these pairs of words to hear the contrasting sounds.
Age, Edge.
Favor, Fever.
Sailing, Ceiling.
May, Me.
Here are some sentences that use the /eɪ/ sound.
Faye hates to play in the hay bales.
We aim to sail in the bay today.
/eɪ/, /eɪ/, /eɪ/.
Nice job!